>> BOXES ALERT BEING TOLD TO
SHELTER IN PLACE AS WELL AS
RAGES IN THE CITY WHAT STARTED
AS A PRISON RIOT HAS TURNED
INTO A WEEKEND OF MASS CHAOS.
VEHICLE SET ON FIRE AND AT
LEAST 11 GAME MEMBERS HAVE
DIED CROSSING THE BORDER INTO
CALIFORNIA ELSEWHERE ON THE
BORDER TEXANS BLAMING THE
EFFECT OF THIS FROM
OUT-OF-CONTROL MIGRANT PRICES
THE CALL FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
AND DEAF EARS BUT WE ARE
LISTENING.
WATCH.
>> 'S EQUITY THE SECRETARY OF
SECURITIES IN THE BORDER IS
SECURE.
IS IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IT IS WIDE OPEN THE BORDER IS
CLOSED AT ALL TO THE BORDER
WILL BE SAY IT IS SECURE.
>> GOING ON I HAVE NO USE TO
SEE VERY SAFE AND I CANNOT
EVEN THE STREET TO DO WITH
THAT WITHOUT SEEING ILLEGALS
THAT THEY ARE MEXICAN PIZZA
THE WORDS OF JANICE THAT IS AS
IT GETS MORE AND MORE
DANGEROUS WITH AND MY AGE AND
EVEN YOUNGER AND THAT IS LARGE
IN THE HEART OF THOSE THAT
DON'T EVEN MAKE IT BECAUSE THE
FAILURE OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION, TO ENFORCE
REPERCUSSIONS FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
SO IT IS IMPACTING.
>> DO YOU FEEL THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES CARES
ABOUT THIS ISSUE?
>> I WOULD LOVE TO HOPE SO
THAT I DON'T THINK SO.
>> JOINING ME NOW NATIONAL
BORDER PATROL COUNCIL, THANK
YOU FOR JOINING THE PROGRAM.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO
LIVE WITH THE PUBLIC EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
BUT YET THE ANSWERS ARE THE
SAME.
>> YES.
IN TEXAS IT'S SOMETHING YOU
KNOW VERY WELL IT'S NEAR AND
DEAR TO YOUR HEART.
WHAT WE SEE IS CHAOS.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE THAT WAY.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID WITH THE
PROTOCOLS OR REMAIN IN MEXICO
IT WAS LIKE A LIGHT SWITCH.
PART THERE WAS A PROBLEM WITH
IMMIGRATION CONGRESS IS NOT
WORKING WITH HIM SO HE TOOK
INTO HIS OWN HANDS AND PUT IN
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS TO
SECURE THE BORDER MORE THAN WE
HAVE 45 YEARS PREVIOUS.
HE HAS A SECURE BORDER BECAUSE
OF THE RIGHT POLICIES IN THE
RIGHT PROGRAMS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK OFFICE HE
TOOK ONE ━- HE GOT OF THOSE
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS AND THEN
ALONG WITH THAT COMES THE
OTHER PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS.
CARTEL VIOLENCE, COMING INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
SO THERE SHOULD BE NO SURPRISE
WITH THE AMOUNT OF DRUGS ON
THE STREET CORRESPONDS WITH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION BECAUSE
THE CARTEL CONTROL SO WE ARE
DOING ON THE BORDERS TODAY.
>> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
THE AGENTS ARE FLEEING IN
DROVES THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE
IT ANYWAY FOR THE SAME THING
BUT I WENT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS THAT LEAVES ALL THE
WAY TO SAN DIEGO WITH THE
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> HOW QUICKLY THIS ESCALATES
INTO DEADLY VIOLENCE IF YOU
SEE BURNED-OUT VIOLENCE AND
HEAR ABOUT THE DEATH THAT IT
CAUSEWAY ON THE BORDER IS ALSO
COMING INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
YOU JUST HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT
WE HAVE SEEN FROM STATES THAT
ARE FAR AWAY FROM THE BORDER
IF YOU ASKED THAT TEN
-YEAR-OLD GIRL THAT WAS RAPED
BY THE ILLEGAL ALIEN THAT THE
BORDER WAS SECURE WHAT WAS SHE
SAY JUST THAT FATHER IN
FLORIDA BY THE FOSTER CHILD
THAT CLAIM TO BE 17 YEARS OLD
THAT WAS 24, I WOULD SAY THEY
SAY THE BORDER IS NOT SECURE
JUST ASK ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENABLES THE WOOD IS NOT SECURE
BUT SIMPLY GOES BACK TO THE
POLITICAL WILL TO PUT IN PLACE
THE POLICIES AND PROGRAMS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THE VIOLENCE WE
CURRENTLY SEE IN